[Musique]
hen ber une jeune fille dans Paris
occupée documentaire réalisé par Jérôme
prieur ou comment à travers son journal
intime cette jeune femme juive a
raconter vous venez de le voir
l'humiliation de l'étoile jaunes les
rafles parisiennes et le camp
d'internement de Drancy avant de vivre
sa propre déportation après cette
bouleversante histoire l'occasion pour
nous maintenant sur ce plateau de débat
dog de s'interroger sur l'anti isme
d'État orchestré en France pendant 4 ans
par Philippe Pétin et le régime de wishy
nous allons le faire avec vous tel
brunemman bienvenue vous êtes
spécialiste de la choix et de
l'antisémitisme en France votre dernier
ouvrage que ce conseil fortement
s'intitule un album d'Auschwitz comment
les nazis ont photographié leur crime
c'est un ouvrage que vous avez coécrit
avec Stéphan hordler et Christophe
kutzmüer Alya Aglan est également avec
nous sur ce plateau bienvenue vous êtes
historienne professeur en histoire
contemporaine à l'université parien et
spécialiste de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale vous êtes auteur entre autres
de la France à l'envers la guerre de
Vichy publiée chez galimar votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule Le rire ou la vie
anthologie de l'humour résistant 1940-
1945 édité chez Folio et puis dans la
collection trac chez galimar nous
citerons aussi cet texte d'un collectif
d'historiens et d'historiennes dont vous
avez fait partie et publié sous le titre
Zemmour contre l'histoire euh ça a été
publié en en février 2022 et c'était en
réponse ce collectif hein et ces écrits
de ce collectif étaient en réponse aux
propos tenus notamment par Éric Zemour
le 26 septembre 2021 c'est sur les
antennes d'europin et de C news Éric
Zemour alors candidat à l'élection
présidentielle euh disait Vichy a
protégé les Juifs français et donne les
Juifs et donné les Juifs étranger alors
ça c'est vrai que c'est une une thèse
qu'on entend souvent des arguments qu'on
entend souvent du côté et de manière
récurrente d'ailleurs du côté de
l'extrême droite française on pourra en
dire un mot évidemment à l'occasion de
notre échange après ce formidable
documentaire de Jérôme prieur qui a mis
en image c'est ce qu'est ce ce journal
intime d'ellenber est tiré de de la
publication de ce journal journal 1942
1944 publié chez Talandier en 2008
est-ce qu'on peut comparer ce journal
intime d'ellenber à celui que tout le
monde connaît celui d'Anne Franck on
peut les comparer làd il y a il y a
aucune difficulté mais la comparaison
montre que ça n'a aucun rapport en fait
Anne Franck c'est un journal de
clandestinité quand la famille est
enfermé dans l'annexe c'està-dire la
cache tandis que henber raconte son
quotidien de jeunes femmes à Paris dans
le Paris occupé jeune femme juive et
tout ce qui est en train de se dérouler
en matière de politique anti sémite mais
aussi son quotidien dans la dans la
société dans laquelle elle évolue qui se
et société qui se ferme de plus en plus
et qui se restreint en terme d'espace de
plus en plus donc c'est pas vraiment
d'équivalent si ce n'est le fait que on
a deux journaux écrits par des jeunes
femmes sachant que Anne frck est
beaucoup plus jeune par ailleurs que
henber donc la comparaison s'arrête
rapidement ce journal d'ellenber est-il
le seul journal intime qui a fait
l'objet d'une publication jeune journal
intime d'une Juive Française non il y a
et une démultiplication des publications
de journaux notamment ces 20 ou 30
dernières années donc il en existe
plusieurs qui ont plus ou moins
d'intérêt tous les documents n'ont pas
la même valeur d'un point de vue on va
dire scientifique ou intellectuel et de
fait le journal d'ellenber se distingue
en raison de l'intelligence de cette
femme de ce dont elle parle de la de sa
vivacité d'esprit enfin voilà il y a
tout qui concourt à faire de ce journal
un document extraordinaire il a été
publié je l'ai dit tout à tout à l'heure
en 2008 chez Talandier sa première
édition en tout cas soit 63 ans après la
disparition d'elenbert pourquoi avoir
mis autant de temps à pouvoir publier ce
ce journal en fait il a une histoire un
peu compliquée parce que helenbert tient
ce journal elle est déporté la famille
puisquelle a plusieurs frères et sœurs
va avoir entre ses mains une pour
résumer l'histoire très rapidement une
copie réalisée par une secrétaire du
père d'éenberg qui a été déport avec
elle mais une secrétaire va
dactyographier le journal et donc dans
la famille il y a ces extraits
dactyographier qui circulent jusqu'au
moment où une niè d'elenber se rend
compte que l'original du journal a été
envoyé à l'amoureux d'elenber qui
s'appelle jean- moravetski effectivement
question dans ce qui évoqué à plusieurs
reprises et donc elle réussit à le
convaincre de lui remettre le journal
qu'elle va déposer ensuite au Mémorial
de la Choa le journal va être intégré
dans l'exposition permanent du Mémorial
de la choix en terme d'objet et Karen TB
archiviste du Mémorial de la choix se
rend compte de l'importance du document
et donc elle va faire en sorte qu'il
soit publié raison pour laquelle en 2008
il est finalement publié mais c'est une
histoire qui se déroule sur une
quinzaine d'années entre le milieu des
années 90 et 2008 en tout cas la volonté
les dernières volontés exprimées par
hlen B ont été respecté ce journal a
bien été transmis à celui qui était son
amoureux dont il a été question dans ce
film Jean mAvec qui lui s'est engagé du
côté de de la France Libre ce la
première édition a été un véritable
succès en 2008 100000 exemplaires vendus
et ce journal d'enber a fait l'objet de
23 traductions partout dans le monde et
donc il a été effectivement considéré
comme un véritable succès littéraire Ali
Aglan je me tourne vers vous parce que
ce journal Hélen ber a commencé à
l'écrire le 7 avril 1942 euh h où en
est-on en France sous le régime de Vichi
donc concernant le statut des Juifs à
l'époque où helenber entame ce journal
alors il faut revenir un petit peu en
arrière parce que dans le
l'antisémitisme de Vichy il y a une très
forte
composantes xénophobe et en fait les
premières mesures qui s'appliquent
évidemment aux Juifs c'est à l'été 1940
c'est ce qu'on appelle la juyétisation
c'est-à-dire euh qu'on va épurer le
corps des fonctionnaires de tous ceux
qui sont nés de père étrangers et en
même temps euh le le même mois de
juillet 40 s'installe une commission de
révision des naturalisations euh qui
vise évidemment les Juifs même si euh ça
n'est pas écrit dans le texte de loi
donc on a euh une batterie de mesures
qui qui est absolument infernale alors
les les les bornes les plus importantes
c'est le premier statut des Juifs du 3
octobre 40 euh qui qui qui a d'ailleurs
fait pas mal de bruit parce qu'il a
fallu justifier sur le plan
international bah ce qu'on faisait aux
Juifs d'autant que la France est quand
même euh à l'époque encore la patrie des
Droits de l'Homme et euh et et donc
surtout il faut argumenter
euh en direction des États-Unis
notamment et l'argumentaire est est est
tout à fait intéressant ce que Baudouin
explique le ministre des Affaires
étrangère c'est que un on on on ne s'en
prendra pas euh ni aux personnes ni aux
bi alors que c'est évidemment l'une l'un
des axes de la politique qui est la
spoliation antisémite et d'autre part
ils sont obligés de réviser l'histoire à
l'envers en disant que voilà à partir du
Front populaire à partir du moment où
Léon Bloom forme ce gouvernement de
Front populaire ce qui avait d'ailleurs
pas plu à Xavier Vala he qui avait dit
ce ce vieux pays galoromain est pour la
première fois dirigé par un juif en
parlant de Leon Bloom bien entendu en
parlant de Léon Bloom mais à l'Assemblée
hein le 6 juin 193
ce Front populaire est censé avoir
ouvert les vannes de de des étrangers
des Juifs étrangers qui sont venus de
partout et qui auraient envahi la France
donc c'est une sorte de de grande
invasion et c'est l'argument développé
par Vichy à l'international pour dire
voilà on prend des mesures contre les
Juifs pour les mettre à part de la
société et c'est ce qu'on voit bien dans
le journal quotidien d'héen ber c'est
qu'en fait on la pousse hors la vie hors
ses cours hors la bibliothèque la honte
d'être stigmatisé par l'étoile jaune
donc en fait pour répondre assez vite en
avril
42 toute une batterie de de
d'institutions et de lois sont déjà
mises en place les principal loi c'est
celles qui vont créer un ministère de
l'antisémitisme he le Commissariat
général aux questions juives qui est
créé en mars 41 en juillet 41 la grande
loi de spoliation dite d'arianisation
des entreprise en juin 41 euh le second
statut des Juifs sur lequel d'ailleurs
le Vatican est consulté on pourra
revenir là-dessus à l'automne 41 et
enfin l'amende du milliard qui est
imposée à tous les Juifs de la scène en
décembre 41 qui est en train d'être
remboursé grâce à un emprunt fait auprès
d'un consortium de banque et évidemment
je peux pas être exhaustive il y a les
rafles les premiers convois qui partent
en mars
1942 et voilà je peux pas tout vous dire
mais enfin en tous les cas tout est là
ouis l'acte législatif fondateur c'est
celui du du statut des juif vous l'avez
dit 3 octobre
1940 qui établit une distinction légale
entre les citoyens juifs et non juifs
les Juifs sont exclus de nombreuses
professions y compris les posts
gouvernementaux les médias
l'enseignement il imposait également des
quotas pour limiter le nombre de juifs
dans certaines professions cette loi
sera renforcée vous l'avez dit à un an
plus tard par une seconde loi concernant
le statut des Juifs question simple
est-ce qu'on distinguit les Juifs
français des Juifs étrangers à travers
ce ce statut d'octobre 1940 absolument
pas ça permet de revenir à ce que vous
avez dit en introduction à propos des
anneries Coles porté aujourd'hui par
Éric Zemour mais qui remonte à très
longtemps en fait à partir de 1945 quand
les hommes de Vichy sont en procès
devant la Haute Cour de justice il
développe des plédoyés PRODOMO et
notamment sur la question des juifs ils
vont expliquer que c'était pour protéger
les juif français donc remettons-nous en
à la loi élaborée par vichis que Alya
vient de rappeler statut des Juifs du 3
octobre 1940 vous êtes membres de la
race juive si vous avez trois
grands-parents de race juive point à la
ligne il y a pas de question de
nationalité ou de citoyenneté il n'y a
qu'une race la race juive peu importe qu
quelle est la couleur de votre passeport
donc il y a aucune protection d'emblé en
fait la six premières du statut du 3
octobre ce sont les Juifs français on
leur retire les droits de citoyens et ça
il faut insister là-dessus l'essentiel
de la du statut des Juifs du 3 octobre
c'est de retirer les droits du citoyen
au juifs français ils peuvent plus
participer aux chambres ils ont plus le
droit d'être élus s'il y a des élections
ils ont plus le droit d'être agent de la
fonction publique ce qui est le propre
d'un national en France donc c'est
vraiment une un texte de loi qui vise
les Juifs français même chose avec la
loi du 22 juillet 41 sur la spoliation
c'est un texte de loi qui vise en
priorité les Juifs français qui sont
accusés soupçonnés de posséder
confisquer la
l'argent en France néanmoins les
premières exactions les premières
arrestations les premières
déportations vont concerner les les
Juifs dit étrangers ce sont deux choses
totalement différentes d'abord il faut
voir que si la loi le statut des Juifs
c'est la loi de Vichi pas la loi de
l'occupant c'est un texte qui est au
Journal officiel de l'État français et
même de la République française à
l'époque puisqu'il est encore intitulé
JF et pas encore j EF donc la loi
française elle est très claire le statut
des Juifs vise les Juifs français et il
y a une autre loi qui prépare en même
temps datée du 4 octobre qui permet
l'internement des Juifs étrangers par
les préfets au seul motif qui sont juifs
étrangers et il faut vraiment comprendre
ça Alya l'a dit juste avant à l'été 40
on déploie des lois xénophobes parce que
dans l'idée dans les représentations de
l'antisémitisme de Vichi les Juifs sont
avant tout des étrangers et les attaques
contre lon Bloom que Alya a notamment
rappelé sur avec Vala c'est de
considérer que leonbloom qui vient d'une
très vieille famille alacienne n'est pas
France
l'extrême droite expliquera qu'il vient
de Roumanie ce qu'on retrouvera encore
dans les années 50 et 60 alors que il y
a pas plus vieux français que Bloom il y
a cette idée que le juif n'est pas
français c'est un pléonas juif étranger
c'est un pléonas parce que c'est ça fait
partie de l'antifrance et ce sont des
indésirable et qui ne sont là que pour
décomposer les valeurs françaises et
donc juif étranger c'est un pléonasme et
il faut le redire et surtout quand on
regarde l'application de ces lois
antisémites aux colonies parce qu'en
fait ça s'étend au territoires coloniaux
et donc en Algérie les Juifs perdent
globalement la citoyeneté tous ensemble
ce que évidemment Vichi aurait rêvé de
faire en France mais n'a pas pu faire
donc le projet il est de les expulser de
la communauté nationale qu'on est en
train
d'inventer vous voyez cette affiche qui
est plus français que lui du maréchal
Pétin voilà qui est plus français que
lui donc on les désigne du doigt comme
n'étant pas français mais c infiltré en
France et c'est et justement c'est là où
il faut distinguer ce que font les
Français le gouvernement français
l'administration française et l'occupant
parce que les trois grands drafes qui
ont lieu en 41 notamment dit du billet
vert ou ensuite celle du 11e
arrondissement sont des rAFS qui vont
viser les Juifs étrangers mais c'est une
volonté allemande c'est pas Vichi qui
qui prépare ces rafle là et pour finir
sur ce point-l la RAF du veldive et ça
Laurent jolie l' a mis en lumière mais
Serge clarcel avait déjà pointé la rave
du V la joli qui est un historien qui a
aussi beaucoup travaillé sur cette
question la rave du veldive on a
quasiment enfin on a plus de 4000
enfants qui sont arrêtés l'immense
majorité est né en France ils sont
français 80 % des enfants arrêtés à
l'occasion de cette rafle du veldive
sont des enfants français donc des bébés
hein sont les ces distinctions juif
étranger juifs français sont très
largement théoriques et il y a jamais eu
de protection véritable des Juifs
français de la part de l'État français
il faut insister là-dessus sinon à
partir de 1945 à partir de 1945 Vichi
adorait les Juifs avant 45 quand Vichi
était au pouvoir il les aimait beaucoup
moins et il a eu aucune difficulté à les
expulser hors de la société française
qu'il voulait reconstruire puisqu'il
s'agissait de reconstruire le pays alors
vous parliez des rafles les rafles
parisiennes bien sûr du 16 au 20 juillet
1942 13000 juifs arrêtés puis déportés
la seule
rafle du veldive que vous avez aussi
évoqué qui elle a lieu le le 16 et 17
juillet 1942
8000 Juifs sont arrêtés hommes femmes
enfants parquet hein dans ce fameux
stade du veldif qui depuis a disparu
hein à Paris mais il y a d'autres rafles
hein 26 27 28 aoû 42 rafle à limoche
clair Montferrand Lyon Grenoble Toulouse
Montpellier Marseille en zone sud en
fait c'est toute la zone libre le 26 a
42 qui est devenu en zone occupée en en
début janvier 20000 arrestations dont
13000 font l'objet d'une déportation à
Marseille au tout début du mois de
janvier
1943 on va voir un extrait du film c'est
le ressenti d'éenber après avoir porté
pour la première fois l'étoile
jaune j'ai souffert là au milieu de tous
mes
camarades il me semblait brusquement que
je n'étais plus moi-même que tout était
changé que j'étais devenue étrangère
comme si j'étais en plainte dans un
cauchemar je voyais autour de moi des
figures connues mais je sentais leur
peine et leur stupeur à
tous c'était comme si j'avais eu une
marque au fer rouge sur le
front c'est le 7 juin 1942 que pour la
première fois Helen ber porte cette
fameuse étoile jaune et subit l'humil
euh du port de cette étoile jaune et
ensuite elle nous décrit ce quotidien
d'e d'une juif française à cette époque
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de cette
humiliation au quotidien de de cette vie
au quotidien que nous décrit Hélen Bert
dans dans son journal c'est une
humiliation qui vise à les pousser hors
de la société car de fait ce sont des
citoyens de seconde zone ils n ils n'ont
plus le droit d'être propriétaire ils
sont mis sous tutelle et et et et donc
cette cette stigmatisation elle a pour
effet de rendre je dirais populaire
l'antisémitisme or ça ça ne marche
évidemment pas mais il faut savoir qu'
qu'il y avait des polices spécialisées
dans la traque des Juifs qui ne porortit
pas l'étoile elle est obligatoire à
partir en tout cas l'internement si on
ne porortait pas l'étoile ah bah oui oui
oui bien sûr mais c'est on devait porter
l'étoile jaune à partir de l'âge de 6
ans je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte et alors c'est des points
on doit coudre d'une certaine manière on
doit pas cacher l'étoile donc en fait
dans ce journal on voit bien qu'elle est
à la fois humilié et fier de ne pas se
dérober quelqu'un qui ne s'est pas
dérober c'est Henry Berkson qui qui qui
a porortter l'étoile et qui a tenu à à
rendre ça public et bon il est mort
pendant la guerre mais ça a été
quelqu'un qui qui l'a portait fièement
et donc on voit bien la réaction qu'ils
ont pu av voir de ne pas se dérober à
ces lois parce que finalement se dérober
aux lois aurait été dire mais on a on va
renier notre confession et on voit bien
dans ce journal d'Ellenberg qu'elle se
découvre juive en réalité parce que pour
elle-même elle n'est qu'une jeune fille
étudiante qui veut passer l'agrégation
qui aime l'anglais qui tombe amoureuse
et qui vit au Quartier Latin et et et
dans un Paris qui est lumineux et et son
chagrin n'en est que plus grand et c'est
ça qui est poignantin la qualité
littéraire de de des sentiments qu'elle
décrit je pense que tous les Juifs ont
eu ce sentiment d'être stigmatisé par le
port de l'étoile jaune et c'était bien
le but c'est vrai qu'on on s'interroge
beaucoup à la lecture de ce journal à
travers ce film pourquoi cette famille
ber n'est pas partie famille ber famille
française depuis la Révolution d'une
bourgeoisie qu'on va qualifier de de
moyenne pourquoi n'ont-ils pas
fui et et et on on apprend avec ce film
ce qui était la vie au quotidien tout
tout simplement de C et parce que parce
que cette question qui est totalement
légitime c'est une question qu'on peut
se poser avec notre vue en surplomb
puisqu'on connaît la suite de l'histoire
or il faut vraiment comprendre plusieurs
choses d'abord la famille ber vous
l'avez dit et Françis ce qu'on appelle
des Israélites les vieux juifs français
enracinés dans le pays depuis des
générations ils sont français déjà la
simple idée que parce que vous êtes
persécuté vous allez quitter le
territoire c'est une forme
l'intériorisation de l'antisémitisme ou
du racisme c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
persécutés qu'ils ont vocation à fuir le
pays qui qui les a vu naître et qui ont
vu naître les générations qui les ont
précédé le pays c'est leur pays ensuite
il y a un autre élément c'est peut-être
pour ça aussi qu'elle se sent presque un
peu intouchable un peu extérieur au tout
début dans les premières années c'est
difficile de croire que la loi vous
persécute c'est quelque chose qui est
assez compliqué et en plus on se dit que
même si la loi est dure la déportation
c'est autre chose la déportation come
commence relativement tard au printemps
1942 et quand elle commence en plus il y
a pas beaucoup d'éco il faut vraiment
attendre vous l'avz rappelé l'été 1942
les grandes rafles pour se rendre compte
de ce qui est en train de se dérouler
autrement dit la familleber jusqu'au
printemps 42 elle a pas particulièrement
de raison de prendre la fuite puisque
les persécutions antisémites des deux
côtés de la ligne de démarcation sont à
peu près les mêmes par contre à partir
de l'été 42 c'est là où ça commence où
le déchaînement de violence et la
déportation commence et c'est là où on
peut commencer à être tenté de vraiment
prendre la fil massivement sauf que
c'est le moment où le père d'ellenber va
être arrêté notamment à cause du mauvais
entre guillemets porort de l'étoile il
aura mal accroché son étoile en tout cas
l'étoile ne doit pas pouvoir être
décroché facilementê donc il est arrêté
il a interné 3 mois à dranc il est
libéré grâce il est vice-président
viceedecteur de l'entreprise cul
ouaisd il seraé sous caution sous voilà
et l'entreprise va payer une caution qui
va permettre de le libérer mais à partir
de ce moment là on est vraiment dans le
moment où la persécution devient de plus
en plus dure dans la capitale et en même
temps les gens une grande partie des
victimes se disent que ça va pas les
toucher eux que ça va toucher les autres
parce que c'est toujours difficile de se
sentir en danger quand vous êtes au
milieu de l'événement et pourant ces
humiliations au quotidien prennent de
l'ampleur moi après moi elle décrit dans
ce dans son journal interdiction d'aller
dans les magasins sauf entre 15h et 16h
sont fermés ou quand il y a plus rien
c'est là où évidemment les magasins sont
fermés plus le droit de traverser les
Champs-Élysées ellees s'étonnent de tout
cela avec ses yeux de de 21 ans 22 ans
la violence administrative faut pas la
sous-estimer c'est-à-dire que ça touche
de plein fouis le le quotidien des gens
la violence de l'administration
française vous voulez dire oui oui
l'administration française qui a
tamponné votre carte d'identité avec une
mention juif
euh la loi qui vous oblige euh à euh à
ne pas vivre avec les autres Français
euh ce qui vous pousse parce qu'en
réalité à un moment donné dans dans son
journal on comprend qu'ils sont poussés
à émigrer justement donc la solution
idéale pour l'État français c'est
l'émigration de même que les nazis ont
d'abord poussé à l'émigration alors en
en spoliant les Juifs évidemment mais
ensuite en 42 la NAS s'est refermé et
euh les déportations commencent et euh
moi j'ai été étonné de du du degré
d'information qu'elle a quand même parce
que elle sait ce que l'on fait oui aux
Juifs du continent européens elle n'est
pas la seul notamment quand elle va à
l'UGIF l'Union générale des Israélites
oui mais mais qui a une assoation
forcé de cette ampleur des déportations
qui commence mais lu giif c'est une
association forcée tout tous ceux qui
sont désignés comme juifs sont obligés
de de d'y adhérer et c'est un des outils
de lapoliation général des des Juifs de
France parce que c'est un interlocuteur
donc sous prétexte de porter secours aux
indigens plutôt à ceux qu'on a rendu
indigens parce qu'on a bloqué leurs
compte et volé le leurs effets c'est un
moyen de de les contrôler donc le gif
c'est un peu voilà c'est quelque chose
qui est à la fois décrié et utile parce
que elle cache d'autres activités
clandestines mais c'est c'est une
manière de de les obliger à faire
communauté on a parlé des des rafles
bien entendu tout à l'heure la question
qu'on se pose c'est vrai de manière
récurrente lorsqu'on parle de de ce
sujet c'est le degré de responsabilité
on a commencé à aborder le sujet avec
vous de l'administration française à
comparer avec ce qui était les consigne
de l'occupant nazi euh où commence et où
s'arrête la responsabilité de l'État
français de ce fameux régime de Vichy en
matière de déportation elle est totale
tout simplement parce que d'abord les
Allemands n'ont pas les moyens d'arrêter
les Juifs en France en
1942 la zone libre leur échappe en zone
occupée la police allemande est très
réduite c'est moins de 3000 hommes qui
ont tout un ensemble de missions
autrement dit d'abord la fourniture des
effectifs par Vichy permet ses
arrestations des deux côtés de la ligne
de démarcation ensuite la responsabilité
d'autant plus forte que ce sont les
administrations françaises qui ont
réalisé les recensements s ordonnés à
Paris par l'occupant comme celui ordonné
par la loi du 2 juin 1941 et mise en
œuvre par les services administratif
français c'est la justice qui condamne
les Juifs qui sont en défaut
d'application de la loi y compris le
port de l'étoile jaune qui est une
mesure allemande mais la justice
française Séville donc tout l'appareil
des administrations y compris les
services économiques et financiers oui
est bien mis sous séquestre c'est c'est
l'économie et les finances c'est tous
ces servicesl qui qui travaillent
sur voilà qui travaille pour mettre au
banc de la société les Juifs et quand il
s'agit de les arrêter et ben tout ce qui
était mis en œuvre avant devient un
instrument pour pouvoir procéder à leur
arrestation ils sont fragilisés en fait
économiquement et financièrement et donc
la question de savoir s'ils partent ou
pas c'est que toute façon quand les
comptes sont bloqués et qu'ils n'ont
plus le droit d'être propriétaire et qu'
sont mis sous tutelle avec quels moyen
trouver des visas d'autant que les
alliés n'ont pas beaucoup aidé non plus
he la Grande-Bretagne a refusé au 300
visas pour la Palestine les États-Unis
n'ont pas ouvert leurs portes c'était
pas du tout facile de s'enfuir et
c'était même la croix et la bannière on
va donc voir un deuxème extrait du
documentaire c'est tout simplement la
manière dont Hélen ber prépare sa propre
déportation j'ai demandé des détails
précis un ou de jours avant le départ on
s'organise dans une chambrée qui
reproduira le wagon hommes et femmes
mélangé
pour 60 personnes 16 paillasses sur le
plancher du wagon bastiau plombé un saut
hygiénique peut-être TR vidé
quand pas d'aération
j'imagine Hélen ber sera finalement
déportée ce témoignage est vraiment
bouleversant elle sera finalement
déportée le 27 mars 1944 c'est le jour
de son anniversaire et elle disparaîtra
malheureusement quelques jours j avant
la libération de bergern
Belson décèdera bergern Belson dans des
conditions assez atroces d'ailleurs il y
aura selon les les décomtes de ser
schlarsfeld qui font un peu référence
sur le sujet
74150 déportés de Juifs de France ont
été déportés durant durant cette période
et puis on va on va citer JAC Chirac en
en en juillet 95 à l'occasion de la
commémoration de la fameuse rave du
veldive qui reconnaît pour la première
fois la responsabilité de l'État
français dans la persécution et la
déportation des juif de
France on se demande après avec recul
pourquoi autant d'amnésie notamment des
présidents de la 5e sur cette question
il faut attendre 95 Jacques Chirac pour
pour pour qu'il qu'on entende prononcer
ces phrases et la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de l'État français dans
ces déportations des des Juifs de France
pour pourquoi cette amnésie avec votre
regard d'historien du côté de Charles de
Gaulle Georges Pompidou valer
giscardestin dis
franoisant avant je distinguerai de
Gaulle des autres parce que de Gaulle
est de Gaulle de Gaulle par à Londres
c'est l'homme qui incarne l'idée de la
France et donc de Gaul va toujours
refuser de de procéder à cette
reconnaissance mais on peut le
comprendre puisque il a incarné quelque
chose et ses successeurs qui s'agit de
Pompidou de giscar ou Teran se sont pris
pour de Gaul c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
repris la posture de De Gaulle mais sans
la légitimité et le rôle historique de
De Gaulle et mitteran était sourd à
toutes les revendications non seulement
des fils et filles des déportés juifs de
France c'est-à-dire les descendants des
victimes ou les victimes elles-mêmes
mais de l'opinion publique dans les
années 80 il faut se rappeler que c'est
l'opinion publique française qui réclame
cette reconnaissance il faut attendre
Jack shirac a l'homme d'une nouvelle
génération lui la Seconde Guerre
mondiale il a très peu connu le grand
conflit qu'il a connu c'est la guerre
d'Algérie où où il a servi et pour JAC
Shira qui a plus le même rapport au
passé même s'il est Gauliste il ne se
prend pas pour le successeur de De Gaul
en matière de perpétuation de cette non
reconnaissance et donc il va reconnaître
en juillet 95 vous l'avez rappelé avec
ce discours très important la
responsabilité qui était déjà établie
par les historiens mais ceux du centre
de documentation juif contemporaine
depuis la fin des années 40 puis les
historiens comme Robert Paxton et
Michael marus ou Serge clarfeld puis
ensuite tous ceux qui ont ce qui était
connu par on va dire les chercheurs et
reconnu par le PO
mais c'est très très tardif de fait moi
j'ajouterais à ce qu'a dit tal c'est que
à la Libération la posture de de gaaule
elle s'explique par le fait que il y a
un risque de guerre civile et il y a eu
une configuration de guerre civile
pendant la guerre et c'est Vichi qui
initie cette guerre civile donc à la
Libération il n'est pas question de
distinguer entre les victimes et je
voudrais rappeler que pendant
l'occupation quand on dit
déportter on parle de la déportation du
travail c'est-à-dire le travail forcé en
Allemagne à la Libération les déportés
c'est les résistants et il faut des
années avant que le mot déportation euh
renvoie plutôt à la déportation par
mesure antisémite ça c'est un premier
point et d'autre part je crois que parmi
euh les les Juifs qui sont rentrés
déportation il y avait une volonté de ne
pas être à nouveau stigmatisés comme
étant des déportés dit ratio et que dans
la masse des victimes ils entendaient
euh ben faire partie en fait et et et on
n'imagine pas ce que enfin les douleurs
de la Libération c'est quand même ces
ces fusillers ces otages ces tortures
voyez et et et et dans la masse
d'horreur il y a les Juifs qui rentrent
de déportation et qui n'ont pas
spécialement envie de se distinguer qui
vont pas demander un statut particulier
dans la masse des victimes moi je crois
qu'il y a ça aussi dans la décision
politique de ne pas admettre la
responsabilité de l'État français parce
que l'État français est responsable de
toutes les autres horreurs c'est quand
même eux qui créent la milice la milice
qui va aider les Allemands à torturer et
arrêter les résistants vous voyez ce que
je veux dire donc le tableau est est
quand même il faut le prendre dans son
intégralité et si à la Libération on on
recommence à isoler les Juifs moi je
pense que enfin c'est comme ça que je
comprends le fait qu'il a pas eu de
mesures spécifiques concernant cette
cette responsabilité dernière question
brutman mais il nous il nous reste très
peu de temps euh y y a-t-il encore des
choses et du grain àout pour vous
historiens concernant cette politique
d'antisémitisme d'État mise en place par
le régime de Vichy énormément et pour
répondre très très vite ça fait 2000 ans
qu'on fait l'histoire de Rome on Contin
continu à faire l'histoire de Rome ça
fait même pas 80 ans qu'on fait
l'histoire de Vichy et de ses politiques
antisémites il reste énormément de
questions à étudier à mettre en lumière
et tout simplement chaque génération
d'historiens apporte ses propres
questionnements en se basant sur ce qui
a été réalisé par les générations
précédentes autrement dit ce travail-
làà même s'il a déblayé le cadre général
il reste très largement à approfondir
dans plein de dimensions pour vous
donner juste un exemple Alya a rappelé
tout à l'heure la mise en œuvre de la de
la politique antijuive dans les colonies
qui demand un énorme sujet comme les
colonies demeurent un immense sujet
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale merci
vraiment à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à à ce débat doc aujourd'hui
après ce ce documentaire consacré au
journal d'ÉEN ber que nous avons
découver ouvert dans dans le cadre de
cette émission pour ceux qui ne
connaissaient pas ce journal publié
rappelons-le en en 2008 aux édition
talentier vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag desbadooc merci à Selma sali et
à Sarah udline qui comme accoutumé m'ont
aidé à préparer cette émission prochain
rendez-vous avec des badooc ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt